I look like an emo lumberjack it's
Tuesday here on its grace and I will not
be vomiting on your comments today I'm
sorry I'm sorry I set a precedence and I
broke it and now you'll never trust me
again but I think you might like this
instead today we are releasing the
official release date of camp Takota and
in honor of that Hannah Hart and I
decided that on each of our channels we
were going to recut the official Camp
Takota trailer to be more of how we
remembered the film so here's my version
little bit up there mm yeah bleep yeah
bleep yeah bleep yeah bleep here bleep
that [ __ ] do what
ma'am mmm-mmm-mmm
bleh bleh-bleh beep beep blip blip blip
burp blink
zoiks more yeah Kuch Kuch Kuch Kuch
Hayden free tissue de frida food
slice slice
that's how I hear everyone all the time
go over to Hannah's Channel and see her
version of the recut Camp Takota trailer
and know that Camp Takota
will be released on Valentine's Day
February 14 2014
that's our exciting make sure you go to
camp Takota come to pre-order because
now there's an official date you don't
forget your parents to be like hey will
you buy this movie for me and your
parents like when does this movie come
out and you're like I don't know and
then they're like this is that crazy
like spam that you get from a prince and
Madagascar ass saying that he's worth 10
million dollars and you're like no it's
these girls and you're like how do you
know these girls okay I don't really
know them they're from the internet
anyway it's official I don't know it's
not when the movie comes out ready good
I know you're distracted by tumblr you
looking at tumblr
ghost when does a movie come out huh
when does the movie come out oh I'm such
a terrible stage mom I'm sorry I will
never do that again
until next week or tomorrow